hello everyone and welcome to today's
panel presentation titled concept to
commercialization thermo fisher's unique
approach to rapidly advancing your
antibody and protein therapeutics this
webinar is part of the cell bio 2021 and
i'm cindy valdez of labyrinth and i will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labries and sponsored by
thermo fisher
for more information about thermo fish
or go to thermofisher.com
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate first by communicating with
our other attendees using our new live
chat feature during the presentation you
can find this live chat located at the
top right of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
finally this presentation does have a
survey for you to participate in during
the live presentation and during the
on-demand period provided by our speaker
and located at the right of the abstract
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation just simply
click on that help desk button located
at the bottom of your screen within the
navigation bar or from the lobby and as
a reminder finally this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits
click on the continuing education
credits link located in the abstract
window below the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain those
credits without further ado allow me to
present today's speakers dr jeff
howe poe and steve lewis jeff ho is a
director of scientific and technical
affairs at the pharma services and steve
lewis is a senior product manager at the
gene synthesis and synthetic biology for
a complete biography of our speakers
please visit our biography tab at the
top of our screen welcome to both of you
gentlemen you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
concept to commercialization
thermo fisher's unique approach to
rapidly advancing your antibody and
protein therapeutics
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
steve lewis senior product manager
gene synthesis and synthetic biology at
thermo fisher scientific
and jeff howe director of scientific and
technical affairs
pharma services at thermo fisher
scientific
steve and jeff you may now begin your
presentations
great thank you maria i really
appreciate you
hosting us for today uh i will be doing
the first half of the presentation and
i'm very excited to be here for today
first i'd like to talk a little bit just
about thermo fisher in general
we are of course a very large
organization but hopefully today through
this webinar will will help with
navigating it and i really seeing how
small and integrated our company truly
is
we take a lot of pride holistically
across the company in our in our mission
to
enable our customers to make the world
healthier cleaner and safer
and today for our presentation we're
going to move into talking about the
agenda
the first half will be primarily about
services provided within thermo fisher
scientific for
early stage
discovery in particular antibodies and
we will talk about why starting with the
gene or gene synthesis is the fastest
way to move ultimately into the clinic
from r d into commercial scale
production
so with the agenda here we're going to
start
really at the beginning of the
therapeutic journey and partnering with
us we're going to talk about
optimization of your gene as well as a
very advanced next generation gene
synthesis as well as advanced protein
expression techniques
and then also how you move from going
from selecting your candidates
from r d or in the r d environment to
ultimately production
from there my partner jeff will be
speaking about strategies for
accelerating your timeline to clinic
mitigating risk as well as building a
foundation for success and how to get
started uh with thermo fisher right
after this presentation
so to provide a little bit of context
thermo fisher scientific has been
working in the infectious diseases world
for for quite a long time and we wanted
to start here in terms of providing
context for
uh today's presentation because we have
a long history working within uh
infectious disease
starting in 2000
we had a very early
infectious disease response
effort that we worked on in terms of hiv
all the way through the mid 2000s and
all the way to today and of course you
can read the whole timeline and if
you're watching this as a recorded
presentation you can pause it um and
take a look at all of the different
details that we've been working on for
more than 20 years in this space
but i'd like to highlight 2020 and 2021
where we really did have an impact a
significant impact partnering with many
companies around the world in terms of
our response to stars kobe 2.
this is a very rapid and very serious
and very interesting time uh not not
just for us in the biotech space but
really globally and it's very
challenging and also rewarding to work
on a lot of these early stage activities
in terms of pandemic response
and so if you have any questions about
some of our activities in that space or
how we contributed to
the
development of some of the vaccines and
therapeutics as an organization we'd be
happy to talk about that we also have
some materials that we'd be happy to
send after this presentation uh to
explain a bit more in depth uh related
to how we've worked
toward developing critical vaccines at
unprecedented velocities
so for today
we're going to start really talking
about the early steps of therapeutics
and vaccine development starting with
the early stage discovery and research
through development
clinical trials and then ultimately
commercial scale production
as i mentioned earlier thermo fisher of
course is a large organization but today
our focus for our webinar is really to
show how you can go from idea all the
way through commercial production in a
relatively seamless way working with our
with our groups in the world in thermo
fisher scientific
and for the first part of today we are
going to focus on the early discovery
and research
aspect as well as development before
moving into
the clinical trials aspect as well as
commercial
production with our partner jeff
so today starting in
the early discovery and research we
really focus on the idea of using
recombinant dna based just on sequence
information at the very beginning to
optimize your protein production
within our production organization we do
have the ability to rapidly create dna
uh from a de novo gene synthesis
processes but believe it or not we
actually start
in a digital way we start with a
proprietary algorithm that really helps
us to optimize the gene expression
uh or the protein expression resulting
from your gene synthesis
and so i'll talk about some of those
services today but in particular i'd
like to start by talking about the
discovery workflow
what you're seeing on the screen is what
we believe to be a very reasonable
timeline for starting at the r d scale
or producing what we refer to as
research use only
targets for protein production
and so we start on the left at the
project design level where we really
begin with just the electronic sequence
design
going through optimizing the the gene
ultimately to result in higher yields of
protein production
and then we can actually do the
dna synthesis as part of that and we
will do the prototyping in-house and
send you your uh gene of desire and
if you'd like we can actually take it
all the way through
subcloning plasmid production as well as
proteins and at any step along the way
at any any point in this timeline you
really do have the ability to choose
what's relevant to your organization and
your needs at a given time you don't
need to go through the entire process to
work with with our group you can truly
pick which aspects of this continuum
that are most relevant for you at the
time of project design
and so
for us today the
the items that are highlighted in red
gene optimization gene synthesis and
proteins are the ones that we're going
to be focusing on
to in particular talk about how you can
move from r d to production in the
fastest way possible
first just for a little bit of context
you have
in the protein expression space
very popular host systems that are used
for expression and so you can do cell
free expression which does not have any
kind of living components associated
with it you can do bacterial expression
uh through
e coli you can do yeast expression
insect expression or mammalian
expression and we'll talk about uh
primarily the complex proteins that you
can make via mammalian expression and we
will talk about how we view that within
our organization
to ultimately provide you with the
highest quality gene
proteins developed from genes in the
fastest amount of time
so as i mentioned starting out with the
mammalian cell lines that are typically
used for protein expression particularly
in therapeutic therapeutic development
you have two that are uh the most common
here the hex 293 or the human embryonic
kidney cells and tro cells the chinese
hamster ovary cells and the benefits of
mammalian cell lines is that you have
the ability to really
do post-translational modifications
as it compares to using another type of
expression system and that's really
important when you're thinking about
developing
proteins like monoclonal antibodies or
by specific or tri-specific
applications because
the reality is the mammalian cell lines
are the way to go in terms of getting
the highest yield in uh the fastest
amount of time at the highest quality
and
different cells whether it's the hex 293
or trio cells
have different uses at different times
and we have that flexibility within our
organization to be able to one not only
offer both but two
as an outsourced service we will also
make recommendations about which ones to
go through for that optimal protein
expression
and so
in terms of transfection strategies
we
have a couple of options that that you
can use here within our gene arts
services and gene art is the name of our
organization who really focuses on that
r and d
range
of protein expression from gene to
protein
and so
our our approach to it from a strategic
perspective is to have transient
expression for four to fourteen days um
which is how long it can ultimately take
depending on the sequence that you are
trying to uh design and then ultimately
express you go through a high efficiency
transfection as part of the process uh
through expression and then ultimately
protein production
uh so that's very fast right and we're
trying to talk about the difference here
between what is transient expression
compared to what is stable expression
stable expression really takes uh months
in a lot of cases you're trying to get a
stable cell line at the end of your
process so that you can ultimately in a
reproducible and scalable way uh make
the protein that you're trying to make
as as your target on
various scales and timelines at
different times of of the project that
you have in mind so to kind of summarize
the way that i like to think about
transient expression versus stable
expression is that transient expression
is really when
you have a lot of squishiness or a lot
of uncertainty around kind of what your
gene sequence is and how it's going to
express when it gets into a host cell
system
and then
after that
if you find a candidate that's kind of
working or you find a sequence
and ultimately clone and then plasmid
that works for you and works at various
scales because at gene art we can scale
up from
24 well plates all the way up to 25
liter production skills at the higher
end you really do start to
get a greater sense of okay here's what
stable cell line development would look
like and that can take months and this
really truly isn't comparing the two it
really is that transient expression in a
way from our perspective precedes that
stable cell line development and the
fastest way to do it when working with
our group gene art services is to go
through our outsourced transient
expression workflow which can be as
quick as four days or as long as 14 days
depending on the sequence and the
approach to actually doing the
expression
so
to kind of summarize at the very
beginning jean art will be there
for
most of the uncertainty that's that's
where we specialize is when you don't
know what's going to happen call gene
art that that is definitely where we
excel in that transient protein
expression space
now
uh focusing on the discovery workflow
here we're going to start at the very
beginning right going from project
design through gene optimization and
then ultimately to
proteins at the very end of the process
but let's start right at the very
beginning
when
you are
starting off we at gene art will ask you
to send us a sequence associated with uh
what you are trying to ultimately
express uh we have a proprietary
patented algorithm known as gene
optimizer
it's our technology that really takes
into account
many parameters to optimize the
mammalian coding region and this allows
us to optimize
expression to
result in the highest yields that you
can you can get right now today we're
very excited about this uh
unique process that we have to
optimizing gene sequences and when
coupled with our production processes
we've seen very strong increases in
terms of yield uh resulting from the
expression that that we do
uh following the optimization
and to talk a bit about uh really just
our world-class performance in this
regard we have a couple of studies that
have been published um and and we can
get access to them and you can actually
just look them up
as well they're they're available but if
you need a link feel free to reach out
to your thermo fisher partner to be able
to
receive a copy
we
have basically compared within this
study uh kinase protein expression and
our gene optimizer software consistently
provided higher expression levels
compared to the wild type gene
as high as 200 percent and as low as 25
expression
we have a very high reliability with
this algorithm it's very unique we have
some really talented folks within our r
d organization who worked very very hard
at the molecular level to really
understand what makes sense when you're
building an algorithm
to optimize that protein expression
so
for those
those proteins that were tested in this
study the technology did provide the the
best results out of out of the different
studies and uh no other optimization
algorithm and that's what you can see in
the one two three four five in each of
the studies uh showed consistent results
and you can see in the paper here
the gene art sections uh just exactly
how much the expression the optimization
how much of an impact the optimization
actually had and it truly does
outperform all other algorithms on the
market today
this is a selected uh slide from another
study that we that we posted
as well or we published as well
where we looked at different protein
expression types so the last one will
focus primarily on kinase proteins but
this really is a study that was done uh
very in-depth to demonstrate that
different types of proteins also benefit
from being optimized through the gene
optimizer uh whether it's transcription
factors to ribosomal proteins the
membrane proteins the cytokines you can
see the amount of increase that the
optimized gene resulted in compared to
the wild type
and it's it's pretty impressive um even
in situations when you are let's say not
with the wild type getting any
expression at all if you look at the
bottom one the cytokines uh in that
particular case the il-2 only expressed
in the event of the optimization uh in
terms of relative expression and and
that's just a testament to how powerful
the gene optimizer algorithm truly is uh
within the gene art environment and then
as i mentioned when it's coupled with
our production processes you're truly
getting the highest chance of the best
yield
that you can get at the highest quality
as well
so moving into a poll question here
if you do have a de novo gene synthesis
project that is currently in process
whether you're doing it in-house or
outsourced to another provider
when do you anticipate you'll require
protein production services
give it a couple more seconds to answer
all right great
and now that we've done that poll
question i'd like to move into talking
about the synthesis and expression uh
part of our presentation again staying
within the the
family within thermo fisher scientific
we're moving on to really that next step
the actual synthesis itself now that
that your genes have been optimized
so we perform really next generation
gene synthesis with within our thermo
fisher scientific gene art group we of
course as we mentioned started out with
gene optimization through
basically bioinformatics and
uh what today would be consider machine
learning processes um you move into a
lego synthesis
then gene assembly then cloning
sequencing and final documentation
uh everything i just went over really
truly is a
sequential process and the process that
we follow within our group to make sure
that you're ending up with not just ex
a cloned gene but we're really verifying
it we're making sure that uh you are
getting increased reliability even with
the shorter turnaround time that that
we're
that we're able to achieve through our
processes in-house
um we
are able to do very high throughput
that's that's something that's fairly uh
impressive at least from my perspective
in in terms of our production partners
at our manufacturing site they're very
fast they've been doing this for 20
years and
uh we have a really excellent team who
not only takes the time to do the
production but will also work to the
point that they can troubleshoot things
that we do protein production all day
every day and that's a unique thing
about this team they're very very
experienced and they are able to really
go from that optimized algorithm to the
express gene and then uh er excuse me to
the to the gene synthesis and then
the clone gene and making sure that if
there are any troubles along the way
that we will do our due diligence to
make sure that you are getting the
highest sequence accuracy uh possible
and so all of these things combined
doing all of that in-house especially
starting with the gene synthesis itself
really allows you to go okay
ultimately at the end of my project i'm
trying to get an express uh express
protein antibody whatever it is and you
start to wonder okay well how can i
increase my chances for the highest
yield possible and that's what we mean
by next generation gene synthesis from
our perspective is really starting at
the electronic level or the the digital
uh from a digital perspective where you
optimize the sequence before even
starting with any of the biology and
then after that gene synthesis you have
the ability to move into bioproduction
with a bit more confidence
and so
after the gene synthesis uh you can
really move into an expression plasmid
and then do actual protein expression as
well
you can see in the box that is uh has a
square around it right now these are
really the next steps in that process on
our way toward protein production
uh you will go from that clone gene to
an expression plasmid before ultimately
doing the expression as we mentioned
before
we
really champion that gene optimizer
algorithm to increase your protein yield
from your
expression plasmid
we have a lot of design flexibility in
how you want to do your plasmid
preparation
which is very high quality and we do it
all in house and that's the great thing
about working with the with the gene art
group within thermo fisher scientific is
because you're starting your journey
with the same group
all the way up to getting that protein
expression step done along the way you
can have full control over how your
process is going so starting from the
sequence like i had already mentioned
all the way through at this point the
expression plasmid or the plasma
preparation gives you that ability to
have uniquely full control as opposed to
if you were to send in your clone genes
to
another provider which you may not have
control over the different steps of the
process one unique thing about the gene
art group is because we do all of these
services in-house for our partners that
provides the unique ability to control
the different aspects of the process as
you progress through it
and then moving into expression uh we do
have a number of flexible expression
scales as i mentioned you can go as
small as 96 well plates um for some of
our more high throughput or small scale
protein expression
services a lot of our partners will
start in the 100 to 300 milliliter range
in terms of their
expression after after the transfection
and as i mentioned when you're looking
toward therapeutic and uh ultim and
vaccine development a lot of the time
we're going to be recommending or you're
going to be
it
coming to us with those mammalian
expression systems which in this case uh
we really prefer the xp293 and xp cho
but we will also do
insect expressions there are certain
proteins that do express
better within those sf9 uh insect cells
and so that's something just to be aware
of that we offer it but truly where we
excel is in that transient protein
expression of those mammalian
expression systems
for the right part of the slide i'll let
you read it i'm going to get into more
detail here in a second but our approach
overall
if you look at the bottom the bottom
line there our approach to bioproduction
is really collaborative we want to be a
strategic partner for you we have a
project management team who will help
you with getting up to speed our local
manufacturing team is also collated
co-located with some of our project
management team and some of our uh sales
support and customer support staff and
so that benefit of doing all of it
in-house with gene art is one great way
that you can really drive that
performance through
working with us through that entire
process
so moving into the next poll question
would you like to receive a quote for an
early stage protein production project
i'll give you a few more seconds to
answer
great
and so for the last part of this
presentation and i really do appreciate
all of your time today uh we are going
to talk about the how we ultimately
increase protein yield through the
actual expression uh and
uh purification processes that we offer
within thermo fish or den art as i
mentioned it you know there's a lot of
advantages to using the xb293
and xpetro mammalian systems that really
express more protein per cell that's
what everyone's trying to get to how can
i get the highest yield for
uh you know the in the fastest amount of
time for the lowest amount of cost using
these expression systems is a great way
to do that
and in our case you can see in that
first red box there
using these expression systems will
allow you to have a higher cell density
meaning on a per cell basis you're going
to have higher
productivity and a higher efficiency
transaction as well and you can see that
uh the protocol is very easy it plugs
right into the five to seven day
workflow that usually uh goes on when it
comes to using the expression systems
but what i want to highlight is
when paired with our gene and vector
optimization as i mentioned
more often than not we are seeing a 3 to
10x yield improvement
by combining all of these factors and so
you may in certain cases see those
benefits on the right or on the left but
they are enhanced when you combine them
with that gene optimization that i'm
that that i mentioned earlier and it's
more reliable and results in a higher
yield than you would otherwise get with
without doing the gene optimization
and as i mentioned i really encourage
you to take a look at those studies i
highlighted earlier
just a quick bit more explanation in
terms of the
gibbs gibco protein expression systems
they're they're industry leading um it's
likely many of the participants of this
call are very familiar with them uh in
terms of
antibody screening immunogen production
uh membrane and intracellular protein
expression uh on the left you're gonna
see heck 293 uh the cell-based system
that can have a protein yield up to one
gram per liter uh in terms of the yield
and on the right xp cho uh you know
really as far as cho cells are concerned
another industry-leading cell-based
system you're going to be getting
protein yields up to three grams per
liter
which in the bio production community
really is uh
toward the upper limit of capability
especially if you're getting them on a
consistent basis like you would be uh
within working with the gene art
framework a lot of the applications for
cho
are some of those more advanced newer
applications like buy specifics other
multi-specifics um and then of course
antibodies are really uh you know
monoclonal antibodies with cho cells uh
those those are really popularized
workflows that
i'm sure many of you on the call are
well aware of an experience with today
and just to highlight a bit about the xp
show
system in terms of the expression levels
uh
you know the tighter in terms of grams
per liter you can see the comparison
versus
the freestyle show which is which is
another chose system the xb293
and then ultimately the xp chair system
and you'll see just a massive increase
in terms of expression levels um
comparatively with this expedro system
so it's definitely
worth uh using we love it in-house at
gene art we do recommend it for a lot of
our mammalian protein expression
projects and we're uh very interested in
helping to identify exactly why
this particular cell
expression system is it might be best
for your sequence but again one of the
benefits of working with gnr is with all
that experience we can do the exact
opposite we can also tell you when not
to use it and when there may be a better
alternative
as well but more often than not this
xpto system we're we're very
very uh big fans of we highly recommend
it and that's something that we're
really um
really happy to be able to use in house
within the thermo fisher um
family of companies
so
moving on to the
final parts in the r d
scale bio production you know you're
going to be interested in purification
and analysis ultimately
we have a number of ways that we can do
purification um we do a lot of them as
you can see in inside that cell
we're inside that box there
we're we're very experienced in this and
we feel very comfortable with it and in
terms of our analysis we have a number
of ways some of our standard processes
are the sds page nano drop capillary gel
electrophoresis
but we can do some other
approaches as well um hplc
when it comes to size exclusion
chromatography also we can and have done
with a lot of our partners endotoxin
detection
that is a process that we do get
requested a lot and it's very important
in particular when you're dealing with
for example in certain cases toxic
sequences which can sometimes happen but
are significantly lower risk when you're
starting with that gene optimization
process that i mentioned earlier
so just talking a bit about our
gene to protein services the
purification approaches you can see
everything in the box there
you know we've got a number of different
chromatography approaches that you can
take to purification we also have
different types of affinity tags but we
also do provide unique customization
options which is pretty unique i would
say to
a provider like thermo fisher who does
do a lot of proteins often times on a
high throughput basis we will do
everything from concentration
adjustments um all the way to things
that aren't listed here
like
choosing custom tubes for example
you let us know what your needs are and
we will do our best to absolutely help
you toward uh making your project go as
smoothly as possible and as quickly as
possible
um and as i
mentioned you know we have a lot of
different ways the filtration and
purification approaches that we have are
not just one
one size fits all
so to speak we understand that every
project is unique and i would go so far
as to say we understand it better
because a lot of times our partners
start at that gene optimization level so
we can see it coming in our production
pipeline and really understand when we
may or may not run into purification
challenges so that's another benefit of
working
for your entire production
workflow at this early discovery stage
with our our gene arts services
here's an example
and this is my second to last slide here
of some of the documentation that you
might receive
early on working with our
gen arts services here we will provide a
certificate of analysis results of the
chromatography for example
we really want to make sure that you
have a lot of confidence in in trusting
us as your outsourced provider for
transient protein expression for those
early services
that you might be looking at you know
it's one thing to be able to do in-house
and feel like you have control over
every step of the process but we
understand that for some people on this
call that can be cost prohibitive from
an equipment perspective or an
investment perspective and so we want to
make working with gene art really feel
like an extension of your laboratory we
want it to be personalized to you so
that we build that trust over time and
really can grow with you we want to help
scale with you uh we you know value
every single one of our customers it's
not that we will just push your proteins
through as quickly as possible we want
to treat every single customer that
comes to us with the uh respect that we
would have doing all of our projects
with our own r d team and our
manufacturing team with all of their
experience they they truly have seen it
all and i can tell you that we're very
proud to talk about
how our team cares so much each and
every day about the projects that they
work on
and finally
i'd like to just share a little bit of
information about upcoming services and
we actually do provide this on a pilot
basis right now the high throughput xp
show expression and purification service
in as fast as 21 days you can go from
sequence
all the way through purified protein
with that analytical report
in either 24 or 96 well played that's
really great for antibody
screening that's something that we have
a lot of partners a lot of the a lot of
the bigger partners that you are
probably very familiar with
like this service because it allows them
to explore a number of targets all at
once before ultimately scaling up uh to
higher scales or production volumes and
so
you know you can save a lot of time a
lot of money we understand things are
getting smaller uh we understand that
needs are getting faster but maintaining
the higher uh quality product that
you're used to and we can say that as we
scale down we are not sacrificing
quality in by any means and this is one
new product offering that we're very
excited to have
and offer you today
and so finally i'd like to leave you
before i hand over to my partner jeff
here with this final question would you
like to be contacted by a technical
sales specialist
to understand more about our protein
services
i'll give you a couple more seconds
great
i would like to pass off to my partner
jeff today representing the pharma
services group within thermo fisher
scientific one of our goals today and
reasons for doing this webinar is to
explain how you can really go from that
r d environment ultimately to commercial
scale production and at gene art we're
very proud to be able to take on your
earliest stages of research uh really
when you're not sure what's going to
happen all the way up to the point when
you feel comfortable to potentially move
into some of those mouth studies or even
ultimately into those clinical trials
and so by working with thermo fisher
scientific you get the benefit of that
early stage transient protein expression
the discovery services and then jeff is
going to speak a bit about how you can
move quickly into clinic
and ultimately to commercial scale
production in one seamless integrated
way within the thermo fisher framework
thank you all
thanks steve i appreciate the
introduction there um so so i hope
everyone's doing well and uh let's kind
of move on uh from the the r d and into
the production of the bio production
side
just want to refocus
the
the audience here a little bit uh as
steve kind of presented
uh
going from concept to commercialization
uh it is quite a big endeavor and and we
i just want to try to break this down a
little bit further
on the next slide as you move um out of
discovery um and into development and
and subsequent stages um
so so thermo fisher scientific will
continue to be your partner as you move
out of that phase
and it's really important that
we overcome uh
or once you've overcome some of those
development hurdles
as presented by steve
we we have
you know the offerings that are
necessary
to get you through the next stages
now for the rest of this
presentation i'll focus on the
development section i will refer to
some of the the clinical and commercial
aspects but i'll focus on on some of the
development and elements uh
in in the rest of the slide deck
so really the key is to really leverage
the experience of a partner
that can offer a really mature platform
which is built
that allows for easy transition uh into
predictable supply chain so that you are
getting the product uh if and when you
need it
so so this development process uh these
solutions that we're looking for
uh to create this new therapeutic is
really critical
first step in moving into some of the
clinical trials and commercial
production
so
our capabilities um
truly demonstrate an end-to-end service
offering uh from dna to patient uh and
and that's really bounded by you know
the foundations of quality um so if i
was to kind of now focus in a little bit
on the process development optima
optimization side
once you come out of that discovery
piece
we're really focused on
the process development elements
of your of your molecule
so that includes things like cell and
development cell culture customization
there could be certain analytical
aspects that that we want to look at
whether it's related to characterization
or some post-translational modifications
or it could be to do with scale-up or
tech transfer and
in-process monitoring
as well as finally you know generating
some material whether that's it's for
that top study or reference standard
and these are really important factors
as we now embark on this journey
of bioproduction and move into both your
clinical trials and and hopefully uh
into that commercial launch
at thermo fisher scientific uh
especially specifically within the
pharma services
we have these world-class uh product
capabilities to really drive you there
these capabilities um are definitely
industry-leading um and end-to-end
and what i mean by that
is that we have been extremely
patient-centric in in delivering over
160 molecules um over 20 years of
manufacturing experience uh really
compressed into
some of the capabilities and service
offerings that that we have to offer uh
to you as our customers and and
ultimately to our patients
um it's truly end-to-end from
development to manufacturing
for both ds and dp as you can see on
this right hand side
moving from both
material packaging distribution and
ultimately logistics for both clinical
and commercial
and that has really uh
paved the way uh for
a lot of success uh for for some of the
molecules that we have developed
for our customers
so you're not alone when it comes to
evolving
the r d pipelines on biologics
here we see
some market projections
as well as um
how we've gotten to this point
uh with with a kegel of 11.4 percent
right this pipeline you know continues
to be extremely strong
even during covert times
now while there there is a wild
wide diversity of molecule types
almost 40 percent in that pre
preclinical phase
revolves around monoclonal antibodies
and that's definitely one area that i
want to try to help
target today is around these monoclonal
antibodies
when we discuss development
the monoclonal antibodies certainly
provide some baseline on timeline and
speed
but with changes in molecular complexity
as you can see here on the right hand
side whether it's things like adc's or
fusion proteins
by specific antibodies
we can use that uh
platform that we've developed for
monoclonal antibodies as a basis
to further evolve uh the scopes so that
we can explore greater design spaces um
as a way to do risk of cmc activity so
um so even though this presentation will
focus uh specifically on the development
and and map side of things
i think the other sixty percent uh we
can certainly tackle with you as well uh
based on again the capabilities and and
experience that we have gathered uh
throughout our 20 years of
experience all right so so then
now that
so let let me pull you back to um to
what we have discussed so far which is
now that you've started your engines on
on discovery and working with g nuts to
generate those first pieces of acid on
the construct and and on the molecules
specifically
your next challenges will likely be uh
on that that first in human you know how
quickly can you get into first and human
and the speed into the clinic as well as
deliver delivering a robust and and
productive process into manufacturing so
so as you move along this path as you
get into clinical and commercial
there's a certain demand
that that is required and certainly
ensuring that you have a process to meet
those demands
is going to be critical
this now puts the spotlight on on things
like selling development process
development and potentially that
scale-up pilot scale
as as
paths that will now
fall on the critical timeline if you're
thinking about speed to clinic
all right so then
speak can be uh formulated in a number
of ways uh at some official scientific
our service offerings are
being modernized with the latest
technology
and automation
throughout the various functions of
development we have invested in
advancements in developing new
technology and automation
that will
take take us there faster
so for example if we we look at you know
some of the automation and latest
technologies that we have invested in we
start with cell line development a
really targeted approach uh utilizing
microfluidics and oep technology for
single cell cloning
moving into some of the process side
where we have the amber 15
as well as pecan robotics to really
facilitate that both
to facilitate both the upstream and
downstream process development um at the
smallest scale
and then
that the the process is and the cell
line i should say is complemented uh by
analytical
and characterization foundations through
the multi-attribute method and and
that's using a workflow that leverages
uh lcms methodology
to obtain
product quality attributes such as
glycans and charge variant data
to now really shine a light on on
product quality
as you move into
bio production
if i was to kind of take one example
let's focus back on uh the the beacon
platform
as mentioned that the beacon platform is
a microfluidic system that uses oep
technology so optoelectric positioning
um and it uses light to help us uh with
single cell cloning uh single cell
cloning traditionally is done through
limiting dilution but with the beacon
we're able to now uh use um
now able to seed cells into a
microfluidic device and then sort the
cells
based on monoclonality
if you look at the systematic on the
bottom
the the instrument is on the left with
the
image in the middle showing how we're
using oep to channel cells uh into uh
what's what's called these nanopins so
channels within the microfluidic device
um and then we're able to assess both
growth and productivity
uh over a a five-day period
but so this has uh introduced a
significant amount of automation as well
as modernization to the to the way we we
deal with selling development and to the
way we introduce a cell line uh into the
bioproduction pathway
so realizing speed to ind or impd um
is
not just uh accelerating uh the the
platform um
the quick the clinic offering is uh is
our offering to which uh has gone
through careful uh construction and
integration of a number of things uh
certainly the first one is around the
workflows uh uh it's around the beacon
it's around the amber systems and the
miniaturization that we're able to to
get out of that workflows um as well as
the analytical methods um so so as we
develop the
the molecule and the process uh that
there's understanding of the process
that's required through various
analytical methods
but i think you know what's more
important um is the robustness of that
platform
with over 80 pd programs since 2017
um and now i've revamped uh xp chose to
s cell line which i'll i'll talk into
lit i'll speak to a little bit more
detail in subsequent slides is really
getting us to the productivity that that
we're looking for
and then also leveraging the process
development experience that we've had
through those programs
and this is then combined with assessing
risk and you'll hear me talk about risk
throughout this presentation
which is really critical as as we
we're thinking about
moving to that ind or impd
but so we talk about timelines we talk
about um accelerating we talk about
speed um so this is our quick to clinic
2.0 timeline
it's accelerated and optimized start to
finish workflow
that as you can see draws on a number of
parallel activities we have taken a
really careful approach to identifying
what's on the critical timeline
and then optimizing the workflow
accordingly and this is the end product
of that approach
you can see that some assumptions are
made through the workflow but what's
truly impressive is that this is not
just completing a gmp batch
at the end it's integrating the pd
to the tech transfer as well as the gmp
operations and finally we're able to
release your dsm dp within that time
frame
and this is all because we are with you
every step of the way to really get you
closer to that ind or impd submission
so so now i have a poll question for you
so if you have a large molecule in r d
or pre-clinical
when is your ind or impd milestone
give you a couple of seconds to
go through that
hey
so so moving along then having seen
the the timeline i'm sure by now you're
wondering how we addressing some of the
risks um and the with the amount of
concurrent work
uh mitigating predictable risk is
certainly embedded in in this offering
in the quick the clinic uh offering um
and you know there are three key pieces
um our approach is really leveraging a
well characterized cell line uh which is
coming up next um
that will help reduce inherent risks uh
and failure points as we move from
discovery to bioproduction
um and then it's about advancing our
platforms so we have invested um heavily
into developing this platform
that really is able to to pull together
the the critical pieces that you need in
getting you to that ind
so then quickly 2.0
has definitely
been focused on a
revamped cell line and that being the
gibco freedom xp os cell line so steve
had mentioned you know some of the work
that
has been done
through his group
and and more importantly
the heck 293 cell line as well the xp
cho
being really uh critical foundations um
in the r d
uh environment in in generating some of
these products and now we've really
turned uh the transient system uh into a
stable one
um certainly for our workflow at the
very beginning where we're doing cloning
and gene synthesis um in some of the
plasma prep work um that is supported
throughout our gene art entity
and and really this is
our transition point where we're going
from discovery
into
bioproduction
what's also
really critical here is that anything
that you learn through discovery is
maintained right whether it's through
vector design or other things
that those are all maintained as we
transition to bioproduction uh we don't
want to lose any
of the really critical
aspects that you put into
the design of your construct
through this initial process so so so
this is really the handshake that you
see
going from gnard
into
the farm services
so when we think about the freedom xp2s
cell line
it's the same robust cell line uh but
there's only gmp bank
uh
that that you've used uh through the
transient system
uh has been adapted for high density
culture um getting to two by seven uh to
around two by seven um
or two by ten to seven cells per mill
um it's been documented in literature um
of its rapid doubling times um as well
as
uh the the ability to be
to produce
a high amount of protein as as you can
see
on your right hand side
definitely in the grams range
between that that three to four
range
and then when we think about uh
the cell line and the stability of the
cell line we've seen good stability
across many of the clones that we've
generated
whether it's for mab or recombinant
protein
and certainly we've seen really high
quality and
very active protein
where we're looking through some of the
analytical methods um so so so if if you
take one message away from this slide
it's to say that
the the cell line the host cell on that
you're using for
the transient
your transient operations will be the
same cell line that you use for your
stables
now consistent quality between transient
stable clones
is really critical um and and i think
that
as steve had mentioned uh certainly for
the expert os
system uh in the transient format we've
seen gram ranges as demonstrated on the
left hand side we've also seen very
comparable uh product quality here you
see some n-glycan
data moving from transients to stables
with a 400 times increase in scale as
well
and certainly
while we see some differences the g0f
still remains
relatively consistent throughout
and the final piece to the freedom xp
os is the the regulatory support
information
um there is a a master file uh for this
particular cell line uh in the form of a
document document um
a regulatory package
that provides
the
the information around the cell line the
history the lineage as was
characterization
there is uh certainly a application data
package that's available
and then
the lineage as mentioned
in supporting your regulatory filing
so i would like to take another couple
of seconds
to for another poll question would you
like to be contacted by a sales
specialist to learn more about the quick
to clinic solution for large molecules
hopefully this is an easy one that you
can just click yes or no give another 10
seconds
all right so so moving along so just a
couple of slides left
now going through the
and introducing to you the the stable
system the stable xp os system and how
it fits within quick to clinic
2.0
we've really laid the foundations
for success
for your ind or impd
so hopefully you know you can see that
quick to clinic um is
formulating the
the pieces that are really critical for
this foundation um where it combines the
process the analytics as well as the
scale-up strategy uh with a really
robust cell line um that is available
now to create your molecule of interest
you know it's certainly through
through some of the slides you could see
that it's been integrated into our
platform
it continues to be royalty free or exit
fee free
and and we we have a
significant body of data around scale up
solutions uh well beyond your ind and
impd milestones
kind of some from my section up
um
quick to clinic is just that first step
um and really getting your molecule
past the the ind and impd
is that first step in the life
the the drug life cycle
i want to highlight here that certainly
pharma services is able to help you go
beyond that
going from both lab to clinic and then
to commercial
so so we have
some additional services which
i'm sure that there will be
opportunities in the future to kind of
share with you
um
so with that i'll ask you to complete
another poll question uh would you like
to talk talk with a business development
executive about your development and
commercialization goals
again a quick and in easy one so
hopefully
you can click a yes or no to that
question
give you another five seconds
all right
so let me sum it up um and i'll try to
sum up steve's section as well if i can
um
so so as steve presented um you know
partnering with thermofisher scientific
can significantly speed up your
development timelines
starting with gene synthesis is the
fastest way um to screen uh and
to screen those clones to identify the
candidates that's necessary
for that next step of wire production
gnr services
through what steve had presented
can accelerate the protein r d timelines
and really simplify your process
and i think ultimately what i took out
of what steve has said is is really help
you come up with a solution um in in
addressing you know some of the
challenges
as you go through that kind of workflow
now while the speak to clinic is one of
the most critical goals coming out of
discovery
um it shouldn't be prioritized at the
expense of other
critical success factors and i hope that
uh you know that risk-based assessment
that you saw throughout the presentation
um helps uh to
um
uh to address that point
and then work with with just like thermo
fisher scientific who can offer seamless
scale-up solutions beyond the ind and
impd milestone
certainly this is
this is really critical
and
we should kind of ensure that uh that
there is complete end to end for any
molecule
or any drug that you're trying to funnel
through that life cycle approach
and finally a quick the clinic
program for
monoclonal antibodies that's designed to
take you from transfection to ind in as
little as 13 months it's certainly
market leading
and you know we balance
the risks um
to the reward as well
so with that um i'll
move over to that final slide uh just
some contact information or any um any
additional
information that you need please reach
out
and
with that i want to thank you for
for your attendance to this webinar
thank you steve and jeff for your
informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
for steve
can we ship clones from another provider
for gene art to perform protein
expression and purification projects
that's a great question the answer is
yes you absolutely can do that one of
the things that we do encourage within
uh gene art services at thermo fisher
scientific is the fact that we can do
the entire continuum from
dna sequence all the way through
expressed
and purified protein in-house so you
will get a higher level of service and
likely a higher level of quality as well
by working with us at thermo fisher gene
art from the very beginning and one
thing that we can do as a result of
doing that is at any point in the
process you have the ability to have
better control over everything sometimes
there's a risk in shipping clones and
that there can be
um you know mislabeled tubes there can
be
uh
shipping conditions or packaging that
are not up to par that we don't have any
control over if we receive it in that
way and if the reason for wanting to do
that
revolves around pricing we're more than
happy to discuss options to really
provide you everything that you need
in-house from that sequence design all
the way through the purified protein
so feel free to contact
one of your thermo fisher partners who
you work with and
we'd be more and more than happy to
discuss the different options available
to you
thank you
and it looks like we have time for one
more question
this question is for jeff
how are you addressing current
challenges around raw material sourcing
with regards to the quick to clinic
solution
thanks marie um yeah no doubt this one's
on everyone's mind uh it's certainly a
challenging environment right now
that said
with this kind of platform approach that
we're taking
there's only a standard set of
single-use components um
and a standard set of resins and media
that that we we would use
and we're able to really
uh procure those well in advance in
preparation for the gmp
manufacturing batch
um and and sometimes even uh before uh
prior to
to that signature so so really it
depends on uh
where where we are in terms of you know
the just
the discussions with with uh
contractual items and things like that
but
but you know there's always you know
with with such a
changing environment there's always
opportunities uh to to go through and
and identify the the critical
uh timeline items that that's stopping
us uh from from moving forward so and
then we're always open for that
discussion so
um
so that would be my answer to that marie
thank you all right well thank you again
stephen jeff for your time today
and your important research
we would also like to thank labyrus and
our sponsor thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye
and
okay so click uh next
yeah
okay yep there we go there you go okay
i'm muting whenever you're ready
so starting at the earliest stages of
the discovery workflow we're going to
start
by talking about the project design and
gene optimization parts of the process
and again we really emphasize the idea
of starting at this level
you can really end up with the highest
quality proteins and the highest yield
and the first part of that process is uh
within thermo fisher gene art services
the gene optimizer we have this
proprietary algorithm that's patented
that takes up to 20 different parameters
to optimize the mammalian
coding region and you can see some of
those parameters there this is unique to
thermo fisher gene art and we
have seen a lot of very impressive
results coming out of the gene optimizer
and i'm going to give an example here on
this slide
the
data that we have and we have published
this study and we're happy to share it
if anybody wants it on uh after this
presentation we'll we'll happily share
it out
we've demonstrated that the gene
optimizer consistently provides higher
expression levels compared to wild type
kinase proteins and so what you're
seeing
is a really high reliability and
performance
especially also against other algorithms
that were tested in this study
in examples one two
three four and five there on the left
it really does outperform all other
algorithms and again that's because we
have a really great r d team who
understands not just molecular biology
but bioinformatics very very well and we
were able to demonstrate just really
impressive higher expression levels but
what's even better is that we're able to
demonstrate it consistently
to really have that world-class
performance that you've come to expect
from thermo-fisher scientific
and then finally this is a another uh
slide that from a study that we did
related specifically to the gene
optimizer and this is just to highlight
that you're going to be getting great
mammalian expression levels not just in
those kinase proteins from the prior
slide but also in other protein types
like
membrane proteins like cytokines like
transcription factors and one thing
that's really interesting is even in
situations when the wild type doesn't
express it doesn't express as with the
very bottom one the cytokines you can
see that only the optimized protein with
the gene optimizer did actually express
and so that's incredibly
powerful i would say from a
sequence design perspective to start
with that gene optimizer to give you
that best chance not just of the highest
yield
protein expression but also the highest
chance of actually getting the best
quality protein that you're trying to
express as well
all right